there's an overlap therefore between the
Trad wife Trend and white nationalism
this overlap can be improvised right
the libs hate Trad wives what's a Trad
wife
it's a traditional wife okay it's a lady
who thinks it's nice to be a lady and
who thinks that the tried and true ways
in which women have behaved for all of
human history are better than the women
who burn their bras and chop their hair
off and practice Witchcraft and Destroy
capitalism and become lesbians to quote
Pat Robertson you don't want your
children to grow up as lesbians one of
these attacks on the Trad Wives has gone
viral I will now bring my not only
intellect but my deep deep love of Trad
wives to bear
to analyze it lately I've been seeing
this thing pop up on social media we are
going to talk about how you can become a
traditional wife how I went from a
raging free the nipple feminist to
becoming a traditional feminine woman in
ways that I live traditionally in our
modern world I don't understand what's
the point of you know arguing with him
immaculately made up women gazing
wide-eyed into their phones singing the
Praises of being a tread wife or
traditional wife
I'll let her explain if you are not
familiar with the term Trad wife it is a
woman who chooses to live a more
traditional life with ultra traditional
gender roles so the man goes outside the
house Works provides for the family the
woman stays home and she's the Homemaker
she takes off at home
I love here this this definition and now
the the horror that this host is Raising
at the prospect of the Trad wives it
basically is just women being normal why
can't you just be normal say well a Trad
wife is a woman who behaves normally at
land like the way that men and women
have behaved for all of human history
and so in our insane culture I didn't do
that for a long time but now I'm
choosing to be normal and my life
improved and the host of this of this
video says oh no no don't be normal the
horror keep going the woman stays home
and she's the Homemaker she takes care
of the home in the children if there are
any thanks for that though the idea of
women being confined to the home while
men do things like go outside and work
isn't exactly new the image of 1950s
Suburban Domesticity has been given a
new lease of Life by the gals on Tick
Tock can you imagine me life of that
boorish brainless
some younger Millennials and Zoomers
have decided to embrace living la Vida
casserole dedicating themselves to
cooking cleaning and child rearing while
their husbands or boyfriends I don't
know chop firewood or go to their job in
human resources and look I'm not saying
there's anything inherently do any men
work in Human Resources I hate so much
about the things that you choose to be
I'm not degrading human resources or if
a man happens to work in it but in my
experience Human Resources is made up of
100 of women I don't know this this
hosts grip on reality seems to be even
more tenuous than I previously thought
and look I'm not saying there's anything
inherently degrading about being a mom
or making nice meals I like cooking
elaborate dinners for that matter my
boyfriend does too but the Trad wife
Trend isn't just a way to talk about the
experience of being a woman and doing
domestic labor
I love she says look there's nothing
inherently degrading about being a
mother about the most beautiful exalted
thing that any person can do on this
Earth there's nothing inherently
degrading about being The Hand That
Rocks the Cradle is the hand that rules
the world of creating life in your very
bodies
unique ability that the the most
beautiful thing that can exist in this
finite Fallen world that we have
and I love she goes and there's nothing
wrong with cooking I love cooking she
she won't even say I like the idea of
having a child and raising a family no
no that's unimaginable but cooking is
fine sometimes maybe okay and here's my
boyfriend
it's saying that being a woman or
expressing your femininity most fully
means doing all the domestic labor men
and women are meant to have rigidly
distinct roles in the home in their
relationships and crucially in economic
activity so this isn't just about
personal choice or individual
preferences right it's advancing a
right-wing police
correct put a pause there that's a
really important point she's landing on
she's she's wrong about the rigidity of
these roles the the idea of having a
traditional marriage is yes there are
distinct roles there are distinct
spheres for men and women in which we
operate but they're not rigid I don't
change most of the diapers at home but
I've changed a few I cook almost none of
the meals but I'll cook every now and
again I don't do most of the cleaning
but I do a little bit of the cleaning I
take the trash out a lot but my wife
will sometimes take the trash out it's
not really her job but she'll sometimes
do it it's not it's not as though you
say well that's your role and that's my
roll and you don't do this and that's
that's that whole idea is very modern
and rationalist and liberal but a
traditional marriage says men and women
are different men and women have natural
inclinations and affinities and certain
things that we can't do I cannot carry a
baby inside of me and so we're going to
rather than try to rebel against nature
and rebel against reality we're going to
embrace that and we think that that will
be more conducive to our flourishing and
she says but to see you therefore it
means it's not entirely but
it's about more than individual autonomy
that's the point it's really quite
simple the idea that all that matters in
this whole world is individual autonomy
that the only moral Criterion is consent
and nothing else matters at all that is
a very modern crazy idea that has
destroyed the distinctions between
everyone in society and especially
between men and women and it's made
everybody miserable I'm miserable so yes
life is about more than individual
autonomy it's about your role it's about
your place in society it's about
recognizing the man is not primarily an
atomized individual man is actually a
social being a political animal
a coupling creature that comes together
with the opposite sex and has good life
so why is this important three things
these women are often really young in
their 20s and they're preaching the
values of submitting to a husband to an
audience of other young women the Trad
wife Trend doesn't exist in isolation
it's linked to deeply regressive
political and social movements such as
Christian and white nationalism and
anti-feminism
so it's obviously yeah it's Christian
Christianity holds it in the beginning
God created man both male and female
created he them Christianity says that
the relationship of husband and wife is
a symbol of the relationship of Christ
in his church so yeah it's Christian
it's definitely anti-feminist feminism
says men and women are exactly the same
woman needs a man like fish needs vice
versa how is it white nationalist this
seems a little crazy yes crazy whatever
that means it's funny they put up a
picture of Nick Fuentes who's a Hispanic
guy
[Music]
but anyway with that put that aside for
a second you're saying that black people
can't get married and have normal
marriages you're saying Asian people
marriages I don't know I know a lot of
black people and Asian people Hispanic
people certainly who have gotten married
and had normal marriages she just
mentions it because white nationalism is
just a euphemism or it's just a synonym
rather for bad it's your horrible when
people say white nationalist or racist
or whatever they just mean it's bad and
it's a bad thing but I don't that
doesn't there's no connection there at
all and anti-feminism feminism is an
ideology which cannot be defended by
feminists it's part of a wider shift of
young people being dissatisfied with
neoliberalism and wanting social change
so let's talk about the way in which
Trad wife culture presents the ideal
relationship men are providers which
means that only they participate in paid
work and make all the financial
decisions he is responsible for the
final say in all of our financial
decisions
that's it with the what the Trad wife
just said is different from what the
feminist lady just said
the feminist lady just said the man
makes all the financial decisions and
what the Trad wife said is he has the
final say in all of our financial
decisions those are very different
things the Trad wife is correct you why
you did it the husband is the head of
household has the final say in these
sorts of matters that's not to say that
the man makes all the financial
decisions in fact in the home economy
the traditional wife makes most of the
financial decisions makes the decisions
on the groceries and often pays the
bills and buys the clothes for the kids
and deals with the school and deals with
this and that and the other thing the
man makes the final decision in as much
as you say okay we're going to live in
this town not this town the kids I don't
like that school the kids are going to
maybe we should consider taking them to
this school I don't really like those
eggs maybe we should get these other
eggs okay maybe but in terms of
practically who is running the home
economy it's it's the wife almost 100 of
the time and this is presented as a kind
of equality while men and women have
separate roles they are equal in their
value insisting on the equal value
between paid employment and unpaid care
work which by the way is a feminist
position hence the wages for housework
campaign of the 1970s gets twisted into
something much more Sinister willingly
giving up Financial Independence yes
when you get married you give up
willingly Financial Independence that's
true men and women both do it and you
get a shared bank account and you move
into a house that you buy together and
you're no longer independent entities in
any way you leave your father and mother
and you become one flesh with your
spouse that's marriage marriage if you
want to remain a totally independent
person then then don't get married the
current administration's New Year's
goals are to tax spend and turn a blind
eye to inflation if this is at odds with
your goals you're tired of the
government playing games with your
savings and your retirement plan then
you need need to get in touch with the
experts at Birch gold today for over
five thousand years gold has withstood
inflation geopolitical turmoil stock
market crashes now you can own gold and
attack sheltered retirement account
Birch gold makes it easy to convert an
IRA or 401K into an IRA in Precious
Metals text Knowles scanner wlas 298
9898 to claim your free info kit on gold
and then talk to one of their precious
metals Specialists with an A plus rating
With Better Business Bureau thousands of
happy customers and countless five-star
reviews you can trust Birch gold to help
protect your savings text Knowles Canada
be Les to 98 9898 and protect yourself
with gold today that is Knowles kwles to
98 98 98
today this isn't all soft filters and
sourdough inspiration it wasn't until
the 1960s in America and the mid-1970s
in the UK that women had the legal right
to open their own bank accounts or
Access Credit which meant that many
women particularly if they didn't work
were entirely financially dependent on a
man and this dependency didn't create
happy marriages this isn't exactly true
what the way the feminists write this up
is that women didn't have any rights or
anything until the 6 the 70s really and
that that isn't true the kernel of Truth
there is that Society was oriented much
more around the family as the
fundamental unit than as the atomized
individual and so as a practical matter
yes a woman was much less likely to work
and live in her own apartment and you
know just get a thousand cats and have a
hundred hookups and not not have ties to
her family if you don't have a job and
you don't have assets since then yeah
it's true you're not going to be taking
out huge lines of credit or anything
like that but it was it it's not because
women were oppressed or there was some
targeting of women by Society it's
because the society was oriented in a
different way a different way that maybe
just coincidentally it coincided with
everybody being happier as Betty frieden
found in her 1963 book The Feminine
Mystique middle class American women who
were living the Suburban dream of
husbands and housewifery were
miserable
in the 1950s the average age of marriage
for women was falling and the number of
children they were having was Rising
in order to roll back on the relative
social autonomy of women in the 1930s
and 1940s post-war American culture had
begun to relentlessly focus on the idea
that fulfillment for middle-class women
meant being a housewife for
working-class women of course they were
just meant to be the middle class
women's nannies housekeepers and help
mates but even with the labor-saving
technology of dishwashers washing
machines what is that little snide
remark and there was this idea after
everyone was extremely miserable from
the Great Depression and this terrible
war and social decay of the late 20s
really into the 1940s then Americans
decided they wanted to just get married
and have a good life and and be happy
it's not as though there were some law
pass that said okay now all you middle
class women you have to get married and
have a good life no they chose to do
that because it was better and nicer but
then she says but not those working
class women didn't get to do that well
hold on I thought you were just telling
me that what the middle class did was
terrible and made them miserable so then
why are you simultaneously complaining
that the working class didn't do it it's
not as though there were some law that
said the working class can't get married
and have this life there was the
Practical reality that in the lower
classes women had to go out and work in
public as well but notice the little
slate of hand here oh things were
absolutely terrible for these Bourgeois
middle class women who got to make a
home and the poor working-class women
didn't even get to do this that well I
thought that was witches which is all
just terrible it's all we're all just
going to complain about everything okay
sounds like feminism to me that's not
funny still the Suburban wives of
America were not satisfied frieden
identified High rates of depression
dissatisfaction and dependence on
barbiturates
women being forced into a life where
they were denied autonomy and the use of
all of their mental faculties was
decimating their mental health they're
submitting their mental health which is
why which is why now after feminism
they're much more medicated much more
applied with these drugs right yeah
though the Trad wives of 2023 talk about
men being in control of the household
finances like it's a charitable act oh
no my stupid in can't cook with
Texas it's a hugely dangerous thing to
do I very much do so ask permission to
spend any kind of money even a dollar I
will ask according to women's Aid nearly
a third I'm going to talk to Elisa
we should have asked about
it at all it was controlled by the
perpetrator a quarter report that their
Partners
she was like do you know in a third of
cases spousal abuse Loosely defined they
would say that their husband controlled
the finances
so what you're telling me is that in the
vast majority of cases the finances were
shared and we're not so you're saying
there's just no connection here between
did you know that in two percent of
cases well right that doesn't
that doesn't it doesn't prove your point
at all I think it kind of suggests the
opposite of your point a quarter of
cases they report their Partners did not
let them have money for things during
their relationship so in three quarters
they did
so in two-thirds they didn't have
the vast majority in all of these cases
contradict your argument
giving up your financial autonomy and
placing it in the hands of your partner
is highly risky if things do indeed go
wrong if you've ever spent time on Trad
wife Tick Tock you'll notice a certain
irony that despite rejecting modern
Womanhood its Advocates love nothing
more than appropriating the language of
feminism in order to advance
anti-feminist goals because men and
women are so different and that is okay
we as women just need to learn that that
is okay stepping into your feminine side
is okay being a mother is okay once more
this dresses up that's not the language
of feminism
no feminism says quite the opposite
feminism says as this woman is saying
now the only virtues that really matter
that really have value are masculine
virtues
and Jerry I'm a man yeah housewife
housewifery yeah whatever it's fine I'm
gonna make a whole long video making fun
of it let's put it fine okay whatever
but it's not nearly as important as what
the men do and all the things that women
traditionally do yeah that's what it's
all this feminine value I know it's it's
not nearly as important as what the men
do and what the that's been always been
the feminist line the conservative line
is no women have something different
that is very valuable explicitly
submissive to your husband as an act of
individualist Liberation but the simple
truth is that if it were possible for
men and women to be socially equal but
financially unequal the Trad wife Trend
wouldn't be popular with reactionaries
and the far right is the very fact that
the far right into normal people
voluntarily surrendering their autonomy
by presenting it as an aspirational
lifestyle which makes it so popular with
conservatives misogynists white
nationalists and religious
fundamentalists I love here she goes
perpetuating these ideas in the popular
culture you're encouraging people people
to fall into these people 's behaves and
ideas
that's interesting do transgenderism
because what I've been told about
transgenderism is that oh no it makes no
difference if young people are being
bombarded with transgender ideas in the
classroom from the White House on tick
tock on all of social media in the
movies and TV no no that's not going to
increase rates of transgender identity
no that's purely biological that's a
matter of individual choice and autonomy
but what if a young girl sees a tick
tock of a happy wife that's gonna that's
gonna ruin her life by drawing her in to
this Cult of normality wife materials I
had to I had to shop and screw her mind
a little bit I had to I was playing like
operation with her brain the Trad life
Trend sits in the middle of an online
content Network drawing together
different subcultures movements and
interests its focus on homemaking
connects to other lifestyle content like
recipes interior Decor skin care soft
life and homesteading which is like
farming but made aesthetic it's
interesting marriage and relationships
obviously links to dating psychology and
self-help and its rigid belief in fixed
gender roles its rejection of feminism
and liberal left-wing or Progressive
values and its emphasis on Christianity
means that it has lent a feminine veneer
to conservative far-right and white
nationalist ideologies one thing that
comes up again and again is this idea of
women submitting to their husbands as a
form of submission to God wives respect
your husbands it's biblical it's in the
Bible do you treat your husband as the
head of the household and Obey him it's
a sacrifice but it is a sacrifice well
worth it and this is meant to be a
reciprocal relationship you as a woman
don't have to feel degraded by
submitting to your husband because the
premise is that his religious beliefs
stop him from behaving badly you want
your wife to follow you be a man and
follow Jesus and give her a reason to
hmm only we had any history of religious
men wielding their power to abuse those
more vulnerable than them I'm surrounded
by idiots
I love how it says these religious men
well hold on all of the women who are
going on Tick Tock here they're they're
speaking specifically about Christian
husbands but then what happens she says
what about these other religious men she
goes to some bizarre Cults that have
nothing to do with Christianity so well
what about that well there are all sorts
of religions Satanism is a kind of
religion it's an anti-religion everybody
has a kind of a religion in that
everybody's got to serve somebody so you
got to drill down a little bit more and
what the drad wives are saying is that
yes we follow the Bible we're Christian
and it says that wives ought to submit
to their husbands but don't forget the
other part that this feminist is missing
says husbands love your wives as Christ
loves his church what does that kind of
love look like well it looks like the
kind of love that would be battered and
scourged and crucified for for God so
loved the world that he gave his only
son
that whoever believes in him might not
perish but have everlasting life that's
that is a sacrificial love that that
this feminist seems to be totally
totally neglecting because of course it
undercuts her argument
like with the example of finances the
idea of submission is that by giving up
her independence autonomy and power a
woman will be taken care of by a good
and godly man but the idea of a husband
loving his wife so does that undercut
the idea of Independence and maximizing
individual autonomy because to love is
to will the good of the other person and
to love one's wife as Christ loves his
church is to pour out everything for
that person so yes the the wife gives up
some of her independence when she enters
into a marriage the husband also gives
up some of most of his independence when
he enters into a marriage that's what
marriage is him he serves Christ but
only one person is grabbing out the
toilet but the influence of
fundamentalist religion extends far
beyond whatever private Arrangements a
couple may have as part of a household
proud wife culture is dominated by
aggressively anti-abortion anti-birth
control and anti-sex Views that's not
true the first two are true yeah it's
dominated by not slaughtering babies and
it's dominated by not withholding
yourself from your spouse not engaging
in sex as merely a way to satisfy your
own individual pleasure sensors but as a
way to give to your spouse because the
husband and the wife become one flesh
and their love is so real that it
becomes another person in the act of sex
that is pretty amazing isn't it that's
the traditional view of sex the modern
liberal feminist view of sex is that sex
is just about titillating yourself for a
little bit and feeling good for a little
and then moving on and doing whatever
you want individually whatever I'll do
what I want an Aesthetics of Wellness
influences Trad wife religious and
conservative Advocates have taken to
tick tock in order to push
disinformation about birth control this
can range from falsely calling the pill
a carcinogenic to hyping out the Rhythm
or pull out methods on social media just
to be clear these are less forms of
contraception than they are playing
pregnancy roulette I'm gonna pause there
so the the ignorance of feminists and
liberals should not Astound me anymore
but it does but when they call it the
pull out method in a very vulgar way
what they might be referring to As
Natural Family Planning which is a
natural way of understanding A woman's
menstrual cycle and it's practiced by a
lot of Catholics and it's
extraordinarily effective extraordinary
it's it's effective north of 98 and it's
based on a much more sophisticated kind
of Medical Science than whatever the
libs say is inject a bunch of hormones
into your body and it definitely won't
have any effect it definitely won't
increase the likelihood that you develop
breast cancer or any other kinds of
cancers even though there have actually
been studies to the effect that shows
that it dramatically can increase the
likelihood of those cancers no no ignore
that kind of science just do it and that
way you can have meaningless sex with
people who don't like you and that will
make you more fulfilled right right
don't think so I just want to celebrate
in the overturn of Roe versus Wade some
Trad wives have Allied themselves with
the conservative right by taking
aggressively transphobic stances
contrasting trans queer and even just
feminist women to their authentic
natural and politically reactionary
model of femininity what happens when
you contrast those two things so if the
big Trad wife social media accounts one
one group is happy and the other one's
miserable anti-mass content to claiming
that feminism and LGBT rights movements
are part of a depopulation agenda
there's an overlap therefore between the
Trad wife Trend and white nationalism
this overlap can be
right what what what what the only
tie-in I can find between any of the
things she's talking about and white
nationalism is the origin of Planned
Parenthood and the founder of Planned
Parenthood Margaret Sanger writing to
one of her directors program directors
saying we wouldn't want word to go out
that we want to exterminate the negro
population that is not only part of a
depopulation agenda but it's explicitly
part of a white supremacist or white
nationalist whatever you want to call it
agenda but that's on the side of the
Liberals and the feminists and the
contrast Contra receivers thanks
and of course all of all of these modern
sexual ideas are part of a depopulation
agenda there's nothing secret about this
one of the most important books in the
late 20th century was a book called the
population Bomb by Paul Ehrlich and the
thesis of this book in the early 70s was
that we have to cut the population
growth and we have to do that through
contraception and through abortion and
if people want to do it voluntarily we
have to do it coercively and these
policies were then adopted in India and
China and had disastrous results and
they're still being promoted today even
though it's BS because since the 1970s
the world population has doubled
malnutrition has fallen to an all-time
low but it's still being promoted by
Bill Gates it's still being promoted by
Oprah it's still being promoted by some
of the wealthiest and most powerful
people in our whole culture is it a is
it a tin foil hat conspiracy theory if
the people promoting the conspiracy
openly espouse it I don't think so
taking place through Aesthetics this
might be using adverts of white nuclear
families from the 1950s to stand in for
the universal ideal marriage or
contrasting the idea deal Trad wife to
the stereotypical Boss who's
always associated with hip-hop culture
and almost always black this reinforces
the idea that the ideal most elegant and
most desirable model of femininity is
white European and one of her examples
was a black guy what's she talking about
more aggressive and More in need of
civilizing but the connections can also
be more explicit one month fluencer
called wife with a purpose issued a
white baby challenge calling on women to
have as many white babies as possible
this is an idea Central to neo-nazism
its adherents justify their violent and
hateful ideologies by talking about the
need to secure a future for white
children and making sure that the beauty
of the white Aryan woman their words
does not perish from the Earth but how
does this how does this work because as
I just pointed out one of her examples
of a traditional married couple was a
black guy with a white woman and she got
very upset because the black guy was
telling jokes about how he had to go in
and re-engineer his wife's brain and so
how does that joke if she's saying that
white identitarianism is at the heart of
the Trad wife concept then how does that
job with one of the handful of examples
that she's using of traditional
marriages in here it doesn't work at all
she's just trying to pick anything she
can do just grasping at straws and so
she finds some comment from some woman
on responding to Steve King and says see
it's all it's all about Nazism or
whatever but then that's been totally
absent from her entire commentary pushed
by white nationalists if modernity is
defined by diversity both of Lifestyles
and of ethnicity then the Trad wife
mocks the return to an Era of Social and
racial Conformity sure put a pause if if
my Grandma had Wheels should be a wagon
but but I don't really see how that's
the premise here the defining feature of
modernity is not diversity I mean
certainly the modern culture creates an
idol out of diversity I'm not saying
that that's not part of it at all but I
think the defining feature of modernity
is decadence an idea of Decay an idea of
merely consuming the cultural resources
that have been built up over many
generations over centuries rather than
adding to them rather than building
things we merely consume we do not
produce children we just live for
ourselves and go on fun trips and buy
nice handbags or whatever people do with
their money we do not ask what are what
we can do for our country we simply ask
what can my country do for me we don't
consider the common good in our politics
we merely consider our own individual
benefit we don't consider the good of
the spouse or the good of the other we
merely consider our own individual
autonomy which is describing those are
all features of the libs and she's
trying to reduce that and say it's all
racist or whatever but no the defining
feature is just a hyper focus on the
self the gratification of one's lowest
appetites and that is bad and that's
something that the Trad wives are
reacting against agency aren't usually
so keen on submitting themselves to a
life of reproductive captivity in the
interest of furthering racism hence Trad
wives white nationalism anti-choice
ideology and religious fundamentalism
aside put a pause there I just love this
idea of the white nationalism and the
anti-choice ideology black people are
disproportionately the victims of
abortion in the United States in many
states they constitute the majority of
abortions this is not an accident this
was by Design the early proponents of
abortion specifically targeted black
people and it's a genocide in New York
City more black babies are murdered in
the womb than are born each year the
most dangerous place for a black person
in New York is in his mother's own womb
okay she said well this is about white
nationalism well if if the white
supremacy keeping the black man down
what are you talking about these would
be very poorly strategic white
nationalists if they're opposing
abortion because nothing advances the
white supremacist agenda quite like
killing all the black people which is
happening right now through abortion
whether the Trad wife trend is an
empowering Reclamation of domestic labor
which is regular old sexism made Palace
both Tick-Tock Aesthetics just look at
the kind of men who approve of it or I
don't like girls who are over sociable I
don't like girls who know lots of people
and only girls who are always out as
someone who you know totally down with
looking the girls have naked on
Instagram it's great but here are two
men both accused of sex crimes by the
way who have made money by sexualizing
women they've crafted their professional
personas around having sex with lots of
different women but here they are
celebrating Trad wives and denigrating
modern women and that isn't because they
want to treat women as a whole better
but because it serves as an excuse to
treat lots of women much worse she
admits in the very first part that these
guys like Andrew Tate they're not
participants in a traditional marriage
and she's saying yeah but these guys
also are criticizing modern feminist
culture and they're also admiring the
Trad wife culture yeah that's true I
don't need to participate in something
to have a point of view about it I'm a
human being with rational faculties and
powers of perception so I can perceive
something I can know something about
cancer without having to have cancer but
what what she's trying to do there is
then say these men are standing in for
what this Trad wife phenomenon means but
no if you wanted to talk about a man who
is participating in the phenomenon of
rat wipes you would find a traditional
husband but she's not going to point to
any traditional husbands because she
knows that traditional husbands have
great lives and are doing the right
thing and are making their wives
generally happy or as happy as can be
and they're they're not so easily
attacked and all the good girls or
whatever that's not about embracing
tradition respect and dignity that's
just old-fashioned misogyny okay so
while I think all these things explain
the political impact of the Trad wife
Trend they don't explain why it's so
appealing in the first place the answer
is simple Modern Life in many ways sucks
it's hard to make the case in an era of
low wages high anxiety precarious work
and extortionate rents that women are
liberated just through entering the
labor market I don't know so she's she's
approaching this through a Marxist lens
and she's looking at all of these
aspects of modern misery inducing
society as merely consequences of
capital and labor and economics which is
neglecting here skyrocketing rates of
hopelessness skyrocketing rates of
identity disorders and that is not
distillable down to merely Economic
Consequences we're made in the image and
likeness of God we have dreams and
desires we have intuitions of of things
Beyond this material world and we we
long for God ultimately and so what
would explain this misery well it might
be I think the fact that we have a
god-shaped hole in our heart that's
that's not being filled it might be that
as we turn away from God whose name is I
am that I am we're left with a pathetic
question which is who am I and and we
try to seek out all sorts of absurd
identities to fill that I'm going to be
a playboy I'm going to be a boss woman
I'm going to be the opposite sex I'm
going to be this that or the other thing
but that's always going to leave us
unhappy we then as a result of that have
a breakdown in society and traditional
community in the Civil Society and so
that that takes away our roles and
because man is a political animal we
take much of our identity from our roles
in society this is why in ancient Greece
for instance Socrates chose to drink the
hemlock rather than to be ostracized
because to be ostracized to leave one's
communities to lose one's identity
that's a traditional understanding we've
lost that that understanding today and
so people even when they're living in a
community they don't understand what
their role is in that Community they
don't understand what their identity is
yes there are some economic problems but
that doesn't even come close to
explaining it it does explain why the
Liberals and the feminists keep running
their heads against a wall why they
don't understand why they're so
miserable it's because life is about
more than money now that leaning in
alone won't make you a girl boss the
relative Economic Security of previous
decades a job for Life housing you could
afford pensions and a debt-free life has
been obliterated in the slash and burn
of neoliberalism pure under 45 where you
don't own a house the future can feel
Bleak you add to that the experiences
that many people have dating like being
or being treated like you're disposable
it's no wonder that people feel
dissatisfied intensely so with the
status quo there is a longing for care
for order for security and certainty and
the fantasy being sold by Trad wives is
that all those things are in reach for
women it's not a fantasy it's real it's
a real baby you can do it
idealized past and that's the thing the
lifestyle being sold is a fantasy it's
fictitious as my colleague Moya Lothian
McLean has argued whatever helps you
sleep at night honey really show images
of domestic labor it depicts domestic
Leisure personally I believe I'm not
meant to work I meant to do this all day
it's like an extended session of playing
dress-up you get to Glide around wearing
floaty skirts and dresses organizing
your snack cupboard and baking bread
look that's my idea of a nice day too
who doesn't like an opportunity to feel
gorgeous and eat nice things
you can do it it's within reach you just
have to give up your feminism a
lifestyle of skin care and sourdough
taking the path of least resistance and
doing so aesthetically at least
resistance I'm gonna pause there path of
least resistance you are resisting right
now the whole culture resists having a
good traditional life you know the the
real giveaway here that This Woman's
liberalism or leftism is a little
uncertain it's a little shaky is if if
she doesn't like
what the Trad wives are doing why
doesn't she just say okay you do you you
live you live your life what does it
bother me what is it what does it bother
you that's what the lips always say to
us what does it bother you if a man if a
huge dude walks into the girls changing
room what was it your problem what do
you care get out of my bedroom
my room leave me alone in this case
this woman actually is sticking her nose
into the private home of these Trad
wives these Trad wives who say I want to
live primarily within my home and within
the home economy so not in public life
so what does it bother this woman it
bothers her because I think she knows
deep down that these women are onto
something and they have something that
she doesn't have that she desperately
wants and she envies them which is a
natural reaction to have but then one
should follow that to its logical
conclusion which is huh the life I'm
living isn't working out very well and
the life those people are living seems
to be pretty nice and rather than merely
write it off as a fantasy and then whine
for 15 minutes on a YouTube video about
it maybe I ought to consider that more
deeply try it out and maybe I could have
a better life too literally the workers
share is declining relative to asset
wealth people seek comfort in images of
Serenity relaxation quiet and
nourishment and people just seek
Serenity whether they're Trad wives or
Instagram babes is tap into that human
desire for respite and channel it into
something else so if your typical
Wellness influencer that'll be woo
flavored consumerism and Trad wives it's
an ideological insistence that if women
make themselves dependent on men they
can find the ease and fulfillment
they've been longing for women are
dependent on men and men are dependent
on women that's reality no man is an
island entire unto himself emotional
nourishment and yeah family life which
isn't predicated on the patriarchal
domination of women work won't set women
free and neither will being ruled by men
it's Freedom equality and reciprocal
care that will yes you have to give up
some of your individual autonomy and the
false promise of liberalism is that you
you can hold on to your individual
autonomy you can be totally independent
but no man is totally independent we are
social creatures you will be dependent
on a man some way or another are you
going to be dependent on a man that you
work for in middle management at the
widget Factory doesn't care at all about
you in the moment you're not useful to
him he's going to throw you out the door
or would you rather be dependent on a
man who loves you who is your husband
with whom you become one flesh and build
a family together it's what everybody
understood for all of human history when
people were a lot happier than they are
right now maybe we ought to consider
going back to one of those ideas maybe
we ought to consider that those
old-timey people in the past had a
little bit of wisdom I'm Michael Knowles
see you next time